I've been involved with the Avatar world
for a pretty long time pretty much since
its inception we were pretty involved
with the story of this game early on me
Brian Joaquim dos Santos and Tim hedrick
who wrote the game I'll bow out for for
a few hours and talked about like where
this could be in the timeline what kind
of story could we do that didn't tread
on what we were going to do in book
three and four but could still be it's
kind of on a standalone story and don't
come back and I've known Mike and Brian
which is the 90s and when avatar first
started going they asked us a dead mouse
to do the main title
Cora I didn't get to work on that one
until now
and we're super excited that they got to
do cut scenes video game activision
setting are there any animation studios
you could recommend and it finally lined
up hey guys welcome titmouse when i show
you the process of how ledger crows made
as a doctor it is my job to kind of
oversee the team and make sure that you
know everyone is in the same style to
match the style the coro
we look at the storyboards and we look
at the key poses and we try to basically
bring the storyboards to life so after
Thurber step is one that the actual full
animation team gets to work hello
Marissa of Korra what's wrong Jinora
where are you so as you can see we got a
room entirely full of talented artists
and we all work together and pre-planned
estas and the sequins we have to make so
as you see like everyone on their only
visual computers has to work on their
own specific shock it's come out just
incredible it feels like the show